how long does it go on until we've dealt
with all our enemies every time we deal
with an enemy we create two more hey
youtubers is Charlie since all of you
have been asking me for a game of
Thrones Martell video for so long I
thought I'd talk about what they're
gonna be doing during season 4 on the
show as well as in the books during
winds of winter I'm also working on a
game of Thrones companion show that will
debut whenever the show comes back
there'll be all kinds of fun stuff and
prizes I'll be posting a separate video
later explaining how that's going to
work be sure to subscribe to get it
so first we'll talk about the Martel's
during season 4 on the show and then
I'll talk about them during winds of
winter don't worry I'll have a nice
spoiler warning to turn the volume down
in case you're not cut up with the books
and you don't want to know about winds
of winter yet here we go Martel's during
season 4 number 1 let's start with the
cast there will be two members
representing house Martell during season
4 including Pedro Pascal as Oberyn
Martell the red Viper and Indira Varma
as ilaria sand one of his lovers and the
mother of four of his 8 sand snakes
there his bastard daughters that he's
turned into trained killers because the
show condenses so much of the book story
for time the characters will only be in
a few episodes despite being fairly
significant during book three number two
let's talk about their episodes pretty
much all of Oberyn scenes will be in
King's Landing with Tyrion and the other
members of the small council most
notably Tywin there's even been some
behind the scenes set photos of Pedro
Pascal in costume interestingly enough
there were also a lot of pictures of him
hanging out with Lena Headey in real
life in case anyone wants to start a red
Viper Cersei ship olaria sand is like
oberyn's Shae except she's not a hooker
she'll appear in a few of Oberyn scenes
but she won't be a large part of Oberyn
secret mission
you can't expect some potential scenes
between her and Sansa Cersei and Shae
though number 3 the backstory there's a
really deep history between the
Lannisters and the Martell's that goes
all the way back to Robert's rebellion
oberyn's sister Elia was Prince Rhaegar
wife she was killed by the mountain and
the whole thing was covered up by Tywin
Lannister so that it wouldn't start
another war after Robert's rebellion was
over because tearing and granted the
Martel's a seat on the small council in
exchange for help during the Battle of
Blackwater in season two oberyn's
brother durant uses that as an
opportunity for them to learn the truth
of elyes death as a result of sure
locking his way around King's Landing
Oberyn gets caught up in the events of
the purple wedding and Tyrion fate so
look forward to some good Pedro
scalp Peter Dinklage scenes house
Martell and Dorne become much more of a
destination for the story and feast for
crows stands with dragons and winds of
winter and thus number four winds of
winter so here's what we have to start
talking about what's going on in the
books so we won't be talking about the
show anymore so if you don't want to
know anything about winds of winter just
turn the volume down I'll tell you when
to turn it back up for the sand snakes
house Martell and the sand snakes become
much more physically present in King's
Landing during winds of winter they're
all part of a larger espionage mission
to learn more about the Lannisters plot
to get rid of Prince Doran of the sand
snakes
Nymeria takes Oberyn seat on the small
council tyene poses as a septa and tries
to get information from the high Sparrow
that's the same high Sparrow that made
Cersei March naked through the streets
Sorella poses as a maester in training
in Old Town and Obara hunts for the dark
star down south remember he's the one
who made Marcella after their plot to
crown her queen failed the really cool
thing I always liked about the sand
snakes were that they always felt so
much more organized and effective and
say like the brave companions or the
Brotherhood without banners I guess you
could say that the faceless ones in the
east are more fearsome but the sand
snakes are my favourite Westerosi
supergroup number five the east so the
Martell storyline and the East is almost
non-existent
after what happens to Quentin during
dance with dragons so most of their
storyline will actually be back in
Westeros number six the mummer's dragon
because house Martell has been neutral
during the war of the five kings whoever
wants to take the Iron Throne from the
Lannisters will need their help because
Aegon is still alive Prince Doran sends
Arianne to verify his identity because
that would actually mean that Aegon is
Prince Doran's nephew I haven't seen any
evidence to contradict that he really is
Aegon so I think that during winds of
the winter he and Jon connington will
join forces with Dorne against the
Lannisters or against King's Landing
depending on how you look at it and
number seven the dance of the Dragons
round two Hagen's planned to reclaim the
throne is in direct conflict with
Daenerys remember the short story the
dance of the Dragons that george RR
martin just published i think that that
will also end up happening again but
maybe not until a dream of spring the
real Martell story to pay attention to
during winds of winter will be this
potential union with Aegon
but if Aegon and Daenerys do go against
each other let me know how you think
it's going to end remember how the
original dance of the Dragons ended it
did not end well
so typically Ward leaves no winners it's
just degrees of lose
okay spoilers over you can turn the
volume back up like I said I'm
developing a new Game of Thrones bonus
show that will debut whenever I start
doing videos for each of the episodes be
sure to subscribe to get everything
you can actually click here to learn how
those bonus videos are going to work I'm
going to be giving stuff away every week
and you can click here to get my review
of that dance of the Dragons short story
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives